the european union has made it easier to
travel across borders in the region as
the pandemic shows signs of easing
travelers can now show a so-called green
pass to prove they've been vaccinated
against covid
so far the bidet administration by the
way has resisted a similar move here in
the u.s chris livesay went to an airport
in rome to try out their new system
chris good morning to you
good morning what we all know the
pandemic has made travel a lot more
complicated for security for the
airlines and of course for the passenger
well now europe is trying to cut a lot
of that red tape
by introducing its own version of a
coved passport
check your ticket check your bags
and now check your covid passport or
green pass as it's called in europe
at check-in passengers can now use an
app to prove they've been vaccinated
tested negative or recovered from the
virus before boarding
like leo roussel on his way from paris
to corsica
we're lucky to have an app that's so
easy to use he says
so we gave it a try in rome now it seems
pretty painless i have the app on my
phone i
show that i've been vaccinated and
hopefully it
lets me pass through we need to
reconnect the people
societies in a safe way ivan basato is
the chief aviation officer of rome's two
airports
during pandemic we need to ensure as an
industry
that this travel is done under certain
safe
margins the green pass is a very smart
safe tool to ensure that these
conditions are observed
to be clear no one is forcing europeans
to use it
many here still carry hard copies of
their covet information
and ask for concerns about handing over
sensitive health data that might be
abused
well there's nothing on the app that
isn't required to travel
already like your name or when you had
your last covid test
but the app slashes the time it takes to
check all those records from different
countries in different formats and
languages
without the green pass travelers like
americans eleni macriannis and james
shea
have to keep track on their own i think
every country
should probably have something in that
other nationalized level just to ensure
the citizens safety and something
electronic versus a piece of paper now
here at the rome airport the chief
aviation officer told me that a similar
system in the u.s would make things
easier for everybody for
europeans going to the u.s and for
americans coming to europe
but considering how politicized things
have gotten in the u.s
he doesn't see it happening there
anytime soon for cbs this morning chris
lives say
rome